bootleg cab podcast man you already know
we had to have my guy Travis Thompson do
what he does and that's wrap his ass off
man his new project is out right now
with uh shout out to Jake one man the
legend yeah a couple of uh Seattle
Legends come on real life let's get
right to it man oh yeah
[Music]
okay okay
trying to keep it boy you old news I'm
right now it's a moment if my presence
fell after register like Anton's like
heads or tails give them hell due to
heavy lifting with no kettlebells got a
spiffy [__] you do it [__] I always say
it smells yeah I'm comfy with the poor
comfy with the rich yeah I'm comfy with
the nurse comfy with the Crips comfy
with the check [__] we trying to change
the City Escape running all their
pockets trying to get my bro a living
way doing sing alongs out in Scotland
they just paid the Navajo to smoke and
start a mosh pit don't believe that
hypers had a Spider-Man your top ten
stop posting them Studio Pictures boy
you ain't locked in I noticed I said it
I'm the coldest made this life a vacant
you vacay with your bonus baby facing
rookie but still moving like a OG I was
slow cooking some ribs inside the
trigger while I wrote this you feel me
tell whoever that it's not a game went
to Raj house on the Russell Block it is
not the same tapping with New York
tapping with the bank kids in South
America is hatting up my [__] name
yeah and I'm not even [__] done hold
up keep going keep going yeah hold up
that is crazy though when we was when we
was out in Europe and [__] people had
tattoos and [__] in my home [__] like
where I grew up and [__] it's amazing it
is kind of crazy
I am not playing no more it's Seattle
[__] and I ain't gotta say it no more
it's some dirty [__] I went through put
some hate in my core but I just smile
and say that it's not the same anymore
you know cause where I'm from 10 is like
a hundred a hundred is like a million
but be weary out in public a million is
some stealing but just be humble and
suck it it's inspiring to see a win but
not if they can't touch it a lot of
three six babies y'all not bored yet
wanna see me switch baby I got Gore-Tex
and them white rapper combos that's just
yours res rooted pen booted plus all
sunburn yeah they want a piece I hand
them none you ain't valid wearing Bubba
coats and Panda dunks independent most
the industry ain't man enough they don't
stand for none yeah uh but we saving
lives at the show come from cool sharks
and men who drove for Miles with dope in
the [__] like I never had a smile and
stroke and my mind is never silences as
positive quotes you know I'm here for
polarizing total violence grease you
with a middle finger and I hope you like
it I just TD she won't see me I'm a
spiky it's okay I'm coming hard don't
gotta hide it it's trapped
regular [__] man come on I need to have
some of these slow whip slow cooked ribs
from the Traeger man hey I'm really I'm
a slow cook Legend now bro like I gotta
I gotta I got it in the backyard bro
making my ribs going crazy bro there it
is
I appreciate you guys watching this
freestyle we got another one coming and
then another one and then another one
and they're all brought to you by our
good Folks at LRG clothing you already
know what it is LRG been keeping you fly
for years they got so much new fly gear
right now
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg when you
check out you'll save 30 off
l-r-g.com another freestyle's on the way
presented by LRG